give you the single hack that has made  me the most productive in my life and  the nice thing is it actually takes less  time than everything else that's going  to give you the routine or productivity  efficiency thing the way it works is you  create constraints and so a lot of us  have you know like had to write a paper  and you had 30 days to write the paper  and then the day before you write it all  in one day which means that if you had  to write 30 papers in 30 days if you had  the constraint and you give yourself a  day for each of them you would have  30xed your productivity and so the goal  is by creating constraints we increase  our effectiveness per unit of time and  so rather than create to-do lists for  yourself create to how long something is  going to take and then place them in  sequence over your week so that you get  so much more done because you have that  line that means that when that line  comes you have to stop